so
so
so
[Music]
so
so
[Applause]
uh
happy sunday everyone conference
championship
weekend this is one we all wait for one
of the best sundays of the entire year
and you just tapped into the way to get
the party started that's right it is the
squad ride live in the bleacher report
app presented by draftkings my name is
connor rogers alongside greg ivory of
course always joining me here and
welcome to louisiana right shout out to
louise louisiana joining the fun getting
in on the fun louis louisiana officially
has uh sports betting legalized so
good for them it's about time you're a
little late we've been doing this all
year we've been doing this a long time
we're happy to have you here all right
greg it's conference championship
weekend this is a big history what are
we hooking up with people with today
connor what aren't we hooking up the
people today with like we gotta we we
got a lot we got custom mods boosts from
our friends over at draftkings of course
we're giving away hoodies
of course we're giving away more jerseys
but connor we're also giving away a pair
of airpod pros
and i don't have those yet and i kind of
want some so i got to hit up the
producer and see if i could finesse my
way to win those airpods pros right here
on the show i don't know that's right
man but but
let me hop in the comments right now i
gotta hop in the comments because
because it's time to give out a hoodie
so i'm in the comments and i see i see
maxwell rexella in the comments saying
49er shout out to you maxwell rexella i
also have weekend lots weekend lock says
cj uzuma
anytime touchdown i like that he was on
my fantasy team this year shout out to
you
weekend locks you are walking away with
the hoodie
all right moving on it is time to do
what we do best that's right before greg
gives out more hoodies you heard it we
got aeropods again how many weeks in a
row are we doing this grand prize it's
amazing so stick around for that but
it's time to do what we do best you know
what we're looking for locks we're
looking for who is getting in the end
zone
on this beautiful sunday we ask you on
social we ask you in the app and here
are the top picks of the week
byron kringle at the top of the board i
think this is byron pringle's debut
on the board and what a time to make an
entrance odell beckham jr right next to
him there he's kind of had a resurgence
with the rams jamar chase your future
offensive rookie of the year
even at plus money debo samuel joe mixon
tyreek hill travis kelsey two very
familiar faces of conference
championship weekend and then cooper cup
who just continues to get it done for
those rams in the biggest moments
especially in the end zone so that being
said we have four legendary picks to
show you you know the deal by now last
one standing takes home the squad ride
title takes home the jersey greg's gonna
boost the odds and then we're all gonna
go bet on that player to score a
touchdown in one of these two games
let's waste no time
and get right into it
the first pick is from the 511 podcast
making their squad ride debut let's see
the pick
yo guys who do you like for anytime
touchdown this weekend
there's a couple of bros looking for
locks at the
house
wrinkles as in
byron pringle the 511 bros
going with big plus money here greg at
plus 190. so we got one on the board
but we need a challenger and who better
than frankie's picks
to enter the arena right now go ahead
frankie take it away three golf balls we
got patrick mahomes
jamar chase
debo samuel we're gonna hit all three
shots which everyone's closest to the
pin we're hammering it
all right we come up here first one
bebo
never had a chance never had a chance
got a clear winner right here
who is it
patrick mahomes plus 225
hammer it it's a lock we're praying for
parley's out here let's go
all right the golf legend frankie giving
us his lock in patrick mahomes plus 225
we got teammates for round one on the
board here greg let him know what we
need before we get into things
we need everybody yes you to get into to
the comments and let us know if you are
riding with my man byron pringle sitting
at plus 190 or if you're rocking with
patrick mahomes sitting at plus 225
connor i'll jump in here byron pringle
plus 190 and
that's how i feel about it i feel real
and i know my guy got into the end zone
in the last two games
i just
there's a lot of weapons patrick mahomes
have he's also a weapon we're i'm going
to talk about him in a minute uh byron
pringle plus 190 if you got the money to
sprinkle it on it then then do it but
i'm staying away and not i think i want
to lean patrick mahomes in this matchup
right here uh connor
my guy's been looking good he's been
running the ball as of late he's it's
the playoffs we know we know it's it's
it's when the the lights are on and you
gotta make those big time plays
everybody's making adjustments
my guys pat's like he's rolling out
can't find nobody he's running he's
looking real sprungy out there connor so
plus 225 you guys know what we can do
here on
the squad ride
i'm rocking with pat here connor which
way are you leaving
yeah i'm going with my homes as well i
just think in the playoffs you're seeing
so many different plays break down and
mahomes looks just as athletic as he
ever has been he's running away from
guys and we've seen him do that before
but when he takes a lot of big hits over
the course of the season sometimes he
comes into the playoffs hoppled we've
seen him in the super bowl hobbled
right now he looks to be at his best he
looks to be fast he looks to be
explosive he looks to be
picking up yards when they're there or
extending plays so i like the number a
little bit better here greg plus 225 for
mahomes for two guys that i think are
almost even in my eyes to get in the end
zone this weekend and like you said
pringle's done it there's no doubt about
that i the pringle bros coming with heat
here it's a good pick right plus 190
it's an off-the-board pick it's not hey
travis kelsey's going to score hey tyree
kill is going to score i like the
creativity but i just like mahomes
number a little bit better here but
where are the comments going are they
rolling with the pringle bros are they
going with the golf legend in frankie
connor
for the people that don't know this
right here is the handy dandy ipad this
is how you get your hoodies this is how
you get
your your jerseys
and this is where i read the takes right
here uh i got
i got
ak-47 big blue says do both it's big
money shout out to you ak-47 also
also hold on my guy space alien says
chase and pringle and mahomes are all
locks to score today shout out to you
space alien um
connor i'm gonna make a decision here
next one i read i'm just gonna say that
they're they're gonna win i see a lot of
pringle in the comments a lot of
pringles
you know what we're just gonna rock with
it i got uh
i got
i just lost it the comments are jumping
today connor
here it is saucy stash saucy stash his
name's braden braden says
bryant byron pringle today so shout out
to you saucy stash
you are walking away with the hoodie and
connor it appears the first round oh man
byron pringle is pulling off the upset
of patrick mahomes in the first round so
byron pringle's moving on to the next
round
yeah it's not often that the people fade
both you and i in the same pick craig
but we went with my homes they're going
with pringle it's okay no hard feelings
it's all right we're moving all of byron
pringle to round two
we're gonna need a worthy challenger it
seems to take byron fringle off the
board so we got larosa 23 coming in and
greg i think you're gonna like this one
we're gonna roll some dice as you can
see we got our players listed out with
all the numbers on the board and we're
gonna let the dice do the talking here
we go
dice is out
we got a four
deebo samuel anytime touchdown score
my man sounded like an extra from
goodfellas or the casino gotta like the
dice legend bringing in debo samuel
-110
so yes a big change in odds but a big
change in player this man is the niners
offense
greg
i think this one gets you a little bit
more excited this is one that i think
you have a little bit easier of a time
signing up for him alright
yes sir yes sir my man d beau samuel he
is the niners offense the 49ers mvp on
offense he plays running back he plays
wide receiver he put him at kick return
put him at pump return those are all
ways my guy can score a touchdown today
but the 49ers
they focus on giving him the ball when
he goes they go
so with that being said we got byron
pringle who's plus money plus 190 and we
got divo samuel who's been getting in
the end zone it seems like every game
you guys know where i'm gonna lean i'm
gonna lean devo samuel here connor but
talk to me
let me know are are you leaning pringle
or are you rocking with d but which way
are you leading in brother
i like debo better i know that you could
boost these odds i think that makes it a
little easier rather than the minus
money i think that's the big difference
for me here and you know with debo
it's interesting because you look at the
targets and he's pretty much averaging
only four in the playoffs so much per
game but when you get 10 carries a game
on top of that greg it completely
changes the dynamic of your potential to
score so i just look at debo and think
he's a threat to ticket of the house on
any single play
i like the match up against the rams
even though he might have to see jalen
ramsey you don't worry about that as
much in a kyle shanahan offense because
you can get him going in motion you can
move him away from corners that aren't
necessarily going to be trailing you the
whole game so
byron pringle up plus 190 it's it seems
good right he's scored the last couple
weeks and the fact that the chiefs can
really run up the score at times and
really get the offense going but this is
the playoffs greg when the lights are on
and the heat is turned up you go to the
guys that got you there and for us for
anyone that's played fantasy football or
his bet on the niners that's been debo
samuel way more than byron pringle these
odds are not big enough difference for
me to make that big pick so i'm rolling
with devo
hey connor man you were preaching to the
people today because the way you just
broke that down my brother
that that that deserves a grammy or
whatever you want that deserves an award
man because that was spot on that was
spot on uh but i'm in the comments right
now i'm in the comments scene what they
are talking about i got cleo i got cleo
with the gift in the comments says demo
samuel for the win guys he has devo
silence in the crowd out there in
seattle
hopefully you guys can see it right
there uh
moving on i got another uh oh i got the
same exact gift
oh there it is the same exact gift from
backyard there it is oh there right
there
there it is uh so bakker you are also
walking away with a hoodie one more one
more connor one more
got another gift cube vision better tuck
your changes debo from a friday
shout out to everybody that i just
mentioned connor it's apparent debo
samuel is moving on to the next round
all right so debo going on to the final
round but we got one more challenger
and you know we got to just bring in
a no-nonsense
stone cold lock legend for round number
three and that's why we're going to w
trammel cause it's conference
championship weekend let's see the pick
w trammell
what's up vr nation we found the
assignments as pop for a lot
the future offensive rookie of the year
jamar chase plus money greg plus money
yeah i like both of these guys to score
this weekend so this is how i'm gonna
find my way how i'm gonna find a choice
which game is there gonna be more points
and you look at the over underline you
look at the point total line bengals
chiefs is set at 54. niners rams is set
at 45. a nine point difference that is
monumental so for me
i i think debo should be the offensive
player of the year i mean i just
submitted my vote for the br picks for
him to be offensive player of the year
but this week i like jamar chase to
score just a little bit more because of
the pace of the game because the context
of the game now greg i know you're on
your niners and you're not a traitor if
you go against devo here where are you
going with this pick
connor i'll i'll keep this one short and
sweet i love both picks here we know
what jamar chase is to that bengals
offense you i mean he's the he's going
to be rookie of the year for a reason uh
now he hasn't been scoring as of late
but he's still been bawling as far as in
the receptions and yards category
putting up an abundance uh i
we know i i know they're in those
bengals uh uh practices and those bring
bengals the coaches are talking
and they know that they have to get
jamar chase inside of the end zone they
know that we know that
vegas knows that
so
i i kind of lean towards jamar chase
even though i do think debo samuel will
get in the end zone as well
the only reason i lean towards jamar
chase is you see it's plus 100 it's plus
money you guys know we can do here on
the squad right we're going to boost it
up so i'm just playing the odds here
connor i'm just playing the odds i like
both picks but i'll lean jamar chase
simply because it's a better number
it's a better number
there's no doubt about that it's this
one to me is i mean there's a reason
they're almost even anyway
so
you can't really go wrong here you kind
of want to parlay them against you know
together get a little crazy uh but we'll
save that for some more fun we have down
the road all right greg let's get this
across the finish line you know who we
rely on to do that people in the
comments what are they saying right now
hey connor the comments are jumping bro
the comments are jumping i i got
alan mendoza who is a niner fan who is a
niner fan al mendoza says give it to my
boy w trevor ain't gonna lie i'm gonna
rock with both but w trammell said he
said darkly i mean he's the dart legend
that's w tremble said jamar chase minor
fan saying he's going to rock with jamar
chase and w travels shout out to you
al mendoza uh your walk away with a
hoodie uh i got i got ilya
vizzov elya vaisov says see ya to the
haters got jamar gridian with a gif in
the comments so uh shout out to you uh
shannon mcguckin says jamar chase is a
lock i'm just going to stop right there
everybody that i mentioned you all are
walking away with the hoodies but connor
it is apparent
the people have spoken if you look in
the comments they're speaking right now
as i speak
jamar chase it appears that he is the
squad ride winner this week so let's
pull up the graphic because i want to
show you guys some magic that we can do
here only on the squad ride with our
help from our friends over at draftkings
you guys see this it says plus 100 poof
there it is boosted it up to plus 125.
shout out to our people at draftkings
hey shout out to everybody that's going
to ride with us let's all
get rich riding with my man jamar chase
jamar chase up to plus
125 and shout out to w trammell this
week's
squad ride leader bringing it for the
conference championship weekend but
we're not done greg we gotta talk
through these match-ups we've got two
games on the slate the best of the best
from the afc the best of the best from
the nfc and we're gonna give our major
our favorite top bets from each match-up
before we do that make sure to get on
draftkings first because for first time
customers you can place a money line bet
of five dollars or more during the post
season and if your bet wins you'll
receive 280 dollars in free bets in
addition to your cash winnings greg that
sounds pretty good right
no yeah connor that sounds awesome uh
but connor and i are gonna go through
these games and um
we're giving you our favorite major
market picks so i need everybody to get
in the comments and tell us what you
think
tell us what you think i'm giving away
hoodies and i'm also giving away
a jersey connor
let's get right to it man let's get to
this first matchup man
let's get right to it the bengals going
to kansas city to take on the chiefs a
big spread for a conference championship
game the bengals are underdogs by a full
touchdown greg when this opened
at seven
right away on tuesday morning monday
morning
i jumped all over this for the bengals
to cover because i thought this line
would move to four and a half five and a
half and it is not it stayed right there
and they're giving you worse odds if you
roll with the chiefs so they're telling
you what they really think of that one
so i like the bengals to cover maybe
it's a bold bet i don't care i think a
touchdown is a lot in any conference
championship game if i was looking to
get away from the spread the over 54 is
a high number i still like it maybe i'd
parlay it with a spread and down to 50
like i usually do with point totals and
parlays so
where are you going greg do you believe
in the joe burrow hype are you going
with over live on pat mahomes and andy
reid
connor i'm gonna actually stay away from
the game as far as i'm picking and
picking the side and i'm gonna look at
that point total and and my
heart my heart man my heart wants the
over i want to see a shootout 54 points
that's a lot i want to see uh similar to
last week last week patrick mahomes
taking on josh allen and the bills that
shootout how crazy that was i really
want to see that but my mind is telling
me
take the under so i'm going to fade my
heart i'm going to fade myself and i'm
going to take the under here connor i'm
going to take the under uh
it's the playoffs i know these two
defenses have been struggling
but it's the playoffs it's the nfc afc
championship and i think that they're
gonna make some type of adjustments
and it's it's just not going to be the
shootout that we think that it will be
conor so i'm going to rock with the
under in this one
i like it i mean you said it earlier
when we were talking fade yourself right
what you think is going to happen
because it seems so obvious there's got
to be a reason 54 is a big point total
and we're gonna see that difference when
we go through the next game greg where
are the comments going what bold bets or
normal bets do they like in this match
up here what are they what are they on
so far
let me see i got uh
i got
space aliens back says bengals and 49ers
are playing each other in the super bowl
so shout out to you we love that love
the take i also got jackboy
jackboy37 says parlay joe mixon over
receiving yards patrick mahomes
overpassing uh this is a lot he put a
whole parlay down uh we got chiefs we
got he said take the rams minus three
and a half in the over in the chiefs
bengals game let's get it greg let's get
me a jersey so shout out to you
jackboy37 i know i can't get you a
jersey right now but i'm giving you a
hoodie shout out to jackboy37 i got one
more in me connor a weekend lock says
who day plus seven he's rocking with you
uh jay uh
puslowski also uh dave
pulowski zero two is also rocking with
you connor and the bengals so uh
the comments they're up and down back
and forth but it seems like you got some
people rocking with you connor and those
bengals
people are excited about the bengals and
greg it's always easier to root for the
new kid on the block everybody's gonna
get behind joe burrow be excited to
maybe see him in a super bowl and holmes
has been there so now he's going to be
the villain it's impossible to not like
patrick mahomes but people always like
the new team the new contender all right
moving on these teams are not new
contenders because you're niners it's
not that long ago they were in a super
bowl and it's not that long ago that
sean mcvay's been there but these guys
these teams want to get over the hump
and win that title and look at this line
greg three and a half points the niners
are on the road home team usually gets
three vegas is telling you that they
think especially with the history
between these two this is an even
matchup between the niners and the rams
and with that thought process greg
simple for me
simple pick here take the points with
the niners take the three and a half
points they are basically saying we dare
you we think the rams win by more than a
field goal i don't if i was a little bit
more bolder i would go niners money line
but i like the safeness of niners three
and a half so
that's where i'm rolling uh where are
you at i know you're gonna be there i
know you're fired up for this game yes
sir i just wanna know are you going
niners points or niners money line here
connor we got a segment we got a segment
later in the show it's called bonus bets
you know we do it every week uh i got a
little treat for you guys then but right
now we're gonna play it safe we're gonna
play it safe here connor
the niners beat the ram six time in a
row the niners beat the rams two times
this year
um
i think if anything conor this is going
to be a close game if the rams pull this
out they pull it out by field goal
if the 49ers pull out i think they pull
it out but i think this is going to be a
really really close game and with that
being said three and a half they're
giving us the hook i just said if the
rams win i think it's going to be by a
field though
hey
take the three and a half right there
the 49ers i mean they on they've beat
this rams team twice they beat this rams
teams twice a man connor said it best uh
vegas think it thinks is to pick em um
so i'm rocking with the team that i've
seen
beat this team twice
i know it's hard to beat the team three
times but
it's the playoffs baby it's the playoffs
so i'm rocking with the niners plus
three and a half on this one connor
it's the playoffs and you gotta wonder
at what point
does kyle shanahan just know sean mcvay
right they were together in washington
on the same offensive coaching staff for
a long time and now you can kind of see
the history here where
it feels like mcveigh in these matchups
greg is playing with more he's got more
weapons he's got the better quarterback
he's got plenty on defense and somehow
kyle just gets it done with these game
plans so at some point yeah it's hard to
beat a team three times it's hard to
beat a team that many times in general
but man you just got to believe in
shanahan at some point
where are the comments going though
right now are they we're so niners heavy
and we've been throughout the playoffs
right we've been we thought we both
thought they were gonna beat the cowboys
i didn't think they would beat the
packers and they did that and now we're
back to picking them here so where are
the comments at this week for the nfc
championship game
i see a lot of a lot of niners fans and
i mean well niners bettors in the
comments you see right there nick you
see nick root plus 3.5 plus punch the
ticket uh
let's see i got ben the goat right there
says sf plus three and a half
easy hot take shout out to you uh
we got also let me see
we got dante here rams money line all
day san fran points okay he's trying to
middle right there uh
i got one more rams and it won't be
close so shout out to everybody even
that was kevin two
216 uh says rams and it won't be close
shout out to everybody that i mentioned
you all are walking away with hoodies um
let's get rich connor
let's try to get rich we got some more
exciting segments coming up where we can
get rich
let's do it shout out to all the
commenters and don't forget to get on
draftkings bet five dollars win two
hundred and eighty dollars in those
bonus bets when you lock down all you
have to do is lock down a money line bet
this weekend it's easy it's too easy
dangerously easy all right moving on
prop lock or drop it one of our favorite
times of the show we are looking at
player props and this week we are
looking at quarterback props that's what
we are focusing on
right now so
that being said greg what are we
starting with right now which one of
these quarterbacks are we starting with
what i need everybody to do is get in
the comments and let us know if you are
rocking with these props or if you're
locking them in or if you're dropping
them just let us know type something out
uh first up we're gonna get it started
with your boy
lsu's finest joe burrow sitting that
over under
uh
291 and a half connor
291 and a half joe burrow talk to us
connor you like that
you like that or you know
one i stay away from and now i'm
definitely not gonna call it a lock okay
i think
if this game goes the way we want into a
shootout he has to get over this mark to
duel it out with mahomes but
we don't know the pace of this game what
if kansas city gets up two touchdowns
and they just want to try to run the
ball and the pace of the game completely
changes so
i think burrow throws for at least two
to three touchdowns i'm not worried
about that the yardage total does scare
me a little bit 291 and a half is a
monster number i know burroughs had
mammoth games in the 400s but greg this
is not my favorite prop that we'll go
through on this list is this too high
for you as well
yeah i think this one's too high for me
as well conor i just mentioned
i just mentioned i want the shootout but
my my mind's just telling me no and so i
have to connect the dots here connor you
said
shoot out my guy joe burrows going over
no shootout
he has to go under so i'm going under uh
i i just don't see my guy slinging the
ball around uh like that today not
saying that he can't but i'm rocking
with the under so i i i'm rocking with
the under as well in this problem
all right speaking of burro if you're a
louisiana better joining us today our
friends over at giraffe kings
they're hooking you up they got a sweet
deal for you for you getting in on the
fun right here in honor of sports
betting becoming legal in your state
draftkings is giving you all the
opportunity to double your money that's
it right there just double your money if
joe burrow completes a pass not a
touchdown
not a yardage total
wow not a certain amount all he has to
do greg is complete
one pass the man has a 70 completion
percentage i think he's going to
complete a pass so you can double your
money
max wager 25 bucks
doesn't get much better than that to be
honest with you right craig
yeah i'm pretty confident my man joe
barrel is gonna get at least one pass
completed today so
that's a good that's a good deal conor
it's a good welcome to the party and to
keep that welcome going we're not done
with these props yet let's get into prop
number two we're looking at his opponent
across the way and patrick mahomes
sending out another high number 293.5
yards
now we know mahomes can do this on any
given day that should not surprise you
it just comes down to what kind of style
of game are the chiefs going to play is
this going to be a shootout so if i had
to go one way here greg i don't bet
against my homes and numbers especially
anything that doesn't start with the
three if i have to go with anything here
i'm gonna roll with the over on patrick
mahomes passing yards total in the
playoffs he becomes a completely
different animal
exactly and i'm right there with you
connor i am right there with you we are
talking about patrick mahomes here we
know what he did what he does like
he's been in he's been in these afc
championship games before um so he's
very familiar and i just can't bet
against the guy i cannot bet against the
guy 293 i did say i want the under to
happen in the game but that don't mean
that the chiefs can run it up maybe the
bengals lay an egg or a couple eggs you
know so i i'm leaning towards the over
here my man pat mahomes uh to put on the
show against that cincinnati bengals
defense uh
so i'm rocking with it connor i'm
rocking with you
all right greg likes mahomes over yards
taking things over to the nfc
the nfc uh conference championship game
here we're gonna start with matt
stafford
over 282 and a half yards greg i'm gonna
go under on this one for stafford he's
had some big games obviously had a huge
one against tampa
i think the niners are gonna put the
clamps a little bit on this one where
i think the rams come out a little run
heavy a little more run heavy than we're
used to seeing with them i don't think
stafford has a bad game by any stretch
of the means i just look at it and go
282 and a half is a lot he doesn't even
need to do that to win so i do not like
this number for stafford unlike mahomes
i'm going to go under on this one where
are you going
connor i'm gonna go under with you but
here's why
last time the 49ers played the rams
matthew stafford got off to an
incredible first half performance i mean
i i'm pretty sure you remember your boy
sean mcveigh in the end zone celebrating
with his own team yes the head coach of
the rams was in the end zone celebrating
with his team in the first half of the
game
connor they lost that game yes they did
lose that game but i want to talk about
the adjustments that were made at
halftime my guy matthew stafford did not
look the same in the second half that he
looked in the first half i think those
adjustments will continue today as far
as in the passing game with the rams and
the 49ers um so i i do think the rams
will come out and look to run the ball
get get play action going in order to
open up the pass but with all of that
being said conor all that being said my
guys over under is 282 and a half i just
i'm not putting money on it the 49ers
third best ranked defense in the league
i'm not putting my money on it um i know
he has cooper cup no he has odell
beckham
will he have the time connor will he
have the time against that niners uh
pass rush so
i'm rocking with the under
yeah i mean keep in mind this is a
niners defense that just held aaron
rodgers to 225 yards and he's probably
gonna win the mvp so i think what and i
don't care about the conditions okay
that's like enough of the constantly
blaming the weather when it's lit it
wasn't a blizzard the entire game they
were still trying to throw i mean the
guy had almost 30 drop back attempts so
i'm with you and i think shanahan effect
he's gonna have i know he's an offensive
guy but he's gonna have his defensive
staff so ready for what sean mcvay wants
to do
it's a lot to ask from stafford all
right and not a lot to ask from our next
quarterback
jimmy g coming in over 50 yards lower on
the total here only 230.5 yards
i'm gonna shock people here greg
jimmy has not thrown for over 200 yards
in the playoffs i'm going over here i
think there's going to be a lot of catch
and run throws schemed up for this one i
think you're going to see a lot of catch
and run to kittle to debo i think
they're going to be ready to go i don't
think jimmy goes out and throws 300 350
yards but i think he gets to the 240 250
mark in this game and this is set so low
because of history but i think jimmy's
ready to go in this one i don't think he
has an amazing game he's not gonna be my
homes out there but i think the offense
he's playing him is going to allow him
to finally throw the ball a little more
and hit this marker i like jimmy g over
i can't believe i'm saying it
i'm right there with you conor don't be
afraid bro don't be afraid because look
at the last time he hit this mark connor
guess who was who guessed the team that
it was against
these los angeles rams so don't be
afraid brother uh
we often see jimmy numbers or low we
often i mean
i don't want to say that but like last
week and the week before his numbers
were low considerably for for throwing
the ball
so there's certain teams that kyle
shanahan i
i would say he has jimmy on a leash like
he he he doesn't let him
flourish like he doesn't just let him go
and be like just throw the ball
uh
but the rams when the 49ers play the
rams it's a team that he lets jimmy g go
out there and throw the ball um
so i i can see my guy jimmy dropping
back today and and just slinging the
ball around don't get me wrong the 49ers
will stay with the run that's what
that's their identity they will stay and
stick to the run but don't be alarmed if
you see some play action deep shots if
you see some play action bootlegs uh
because
kyle shanahan lets my guy jimmy g sling
the ball against these rams so i'm
taking the yogurt
i like it over for jimmy g
now we gotta ask where are the comments
going because greg's got not just
hoodies but an nfl jersey of your choice
to give away here so get in on the prop
action everybody which quarterback over
under do you like is there another prop
you're getting in on for these games
greg where are they going right now
i got
they're all over the place in the
comments right now connor uh you guys
you see you guys can see like literally
they're jumping in on the screen right
now um i got
we're getting spammed by space alien he
keeps on putting the same pick uh but i
got m kent 93 says 49ers will roll the
ramps today shout out to you m kit
you're rocking away with the hoodie um
i also have
also have here we go peter raider909
says jimmy g over on the over
yes with the gift uh h
h johnson 101 says over jimmy g
uh so they're rocking with the garoppolo
over see jackboy37 there shout out to
everybody that i mentioned you guys are
all walking away with hoodies connor we
might be on to something with that jimmy
g over brother
i'm surprised people like it i i like
that people are not fading the jimmy g
pick we are
we're all in can't believe we're saying
it and speaking of those comments
we got a couple to look through from
this week basically we want to know your
best bets for championship sunday we
want your takes on these games so let's
get into it greg
what's the first one that we're working
with here
connor uh i'm here brother my ear my ifb
dropped out of my ear but i'm here and
this is the comment from the boss he
says niners ground game and suffocating
defense beat the rams tonight the
bengals hang around for a while until
the chiefs pull away in the second half
and win by a couple of touchdowns connor
this is the boss talking right now this
is the boss talking
what's your take on this do you like
this or do you not
the boss bringing the nfl matchup level
analysis here
listen i like some of the takes here i
i'm high on the niners defense in this
game there's no doubt about that i i the
only problem i have with this one greg
is the chief's pulling away by a couple
touchdowns at the end that's a little
rich for me as the bengals better i
think the bengals can back door cover
that game or i think the bengals can
hang around but i love what the boss is
saying making really good points all
around we know what this niners ground
game can do the rams have to be ready
for it but the rams as talented as they
are aaron donald von miller those guys
up front you got to be careful that
those guys don't overshoot as pass
rushers and get beat by the ground
attack but they'll be ready to go
prepared for that love what the boss has
to say um then i think i think you do
too i have a feeling that you're rolling
with the boss on this one
yeah i like i just like how the boss
just laid it out for us connor he just
laid it out
told us what's going to happen uh
and just yeah i mean i i like the way
the boss rose just lays it out straight
for us let's move on to the next
commenter we have s
ross
21. sros21 says rams will blow out san
francisco bengals will squeak out by a
field goal
i don't know about this one connor i
don't know about this one but talk to us
talk to the people
do you like this one or do you not
all right so let me start with the
second point and then throw the first
point back to you if the bengals are
going to win this game that's exactly
right it's going to be a nail-biting
field goal it's going to the bills and
chiefs we already saw it right we saw a
punch for punch counter punch counter
punch haymaker haymaker and then you
look up and the bell rings and
somebody's got a higher total and that's
what happened in that game now when it
comes down to the bengals
they're just going to have to keep
throwing in this one they're gonna have
to keep trying to keep up with the
shootout that it is
and the only way they win is if they can
control the clock at the end and kick
that field goal to close it out take the
ball out of mahomes hand so steve is on
the money with that one
the first one greg
rams will blow out san francisco
i'm not expecting any blowouts for the
conference championship games i already
said i like the niners plus three and a
half i don't see them losing by more
than a field goal
speak to this one greg blown out with
you in attendance
nah man this this 49ers team i don't
think that they're gonna get blown out
they've been resilient all year we saw
what they did in week 18 against this
same rams team when they were down big
at halftime and came back and won that
game you also saw the resiliency last
week against those packers down seven at
halftime came back and won that game
against the the mvp of this season i i
just it's hard for me to see uh a
blowout and that's not even a fan
speaking but that's just being a realist
that's being a realist this 49ers team
they started off they were struggling at
first they struggled out the gates
connor and now look at him they're in
the nfc championship game uh so
this team just has a lot of fight they
had a lot of resiliency and i just can't
see them getting blown out today
no that's a lot uh a lot to go with here
so you
somebody's got to take home the hoodie
here greg i know you like to show love
to the doubters a lot are you giving it
to the doubter and steve or is the boss
a level analysis taking it home
connor we go rock with the boss we go
rock with the boss he gave us a uh he
gave us a real in-depth uh description
of what he thinks is gonna happen this
weekend so uh we're gonna rock with the
boss and um
hook him up with the jersey of his
choice
all right before we move on to boldest
best which i know everybody's
highly anticipating anxiously waiting
for we got something special something
special planned right now as you know
one of our favorite props all year to
ride has been the no score first drive
greg and i did it for every monday night
football game this year we've kept an
eye on it for most of the playoff games
this year
and since it is the playoffs our friends
at draftkings
spicy things up just a little bit for us
greg what do they have for this week's
no score first drive
that's right connor the question is this
weekend
will there will the opening offense
score in the first drive of the rams
49ers game draftkings is boosting those
odds to plus
200 my friend
uh i'll just jump in i'll just jump in
the first drive go ahead
i'll jump in
there's a it's a low scoring uh it's a
low point total for a reason connor i'm
gonna rock with no i think the rams are
gonna get the ball first and then i
think they're gonna get uh
they're gonna get stopped i think
they're gonna get stopped 49ers get the
ball first
kyle shanahan's first 15. he likes to
draw him up but they they've been
getting off the slow starts they got off
to a slow start in green bay so uh i
think i'm gonna rock with the no which
way are you leading
i'm going with you i'm going with no
score as well i think there's gonna be a
feeling out process in this game right i
think both teams are going to be content
to try to establish the run early on you
might even see my most hated strategy of
run run pass put yourself in third and
long
i look at this greg i don't think either
team is in a rush
you know they'd love to come out of the
gate and score early but i don't think
they're going to take the chances to do
so not with jimmy and honestly not with
stafford who is interception chrome
against a niners defense that looks
really good right now so
i'm on it i'm on the no score first
drive as well
uh what are the comments thing right now
are they going with no points or are
they rolling with uh somebody coming out
of the gate and making a bold play
uh space alien says the bengals score
first drive chiefs don't rams do 49ers
do i got ny22gc
says uh no no no first drive td in rams
san francisco field goal rams first
drive okay so i guess they're going with
a field goal shout out to you uh here we
go i got another one the comments are
jumping bro samuel s young 37 says
rocking on the no
score first drive they are riding with
the no square first drive uh shout out
to everybody that i mentioned you all
are walking away with hoodies
and shout out to frank in the comments
who said somebody get these spamming
losers out of the comments so shout out
to frank in there uh guys you don't have
to spam us greg's reading it all we're
gonna get to your picks you're gonna get
the hoodies and we're gonna get to
boldest bets right now because it's time
to have some fun
greg you got a jersey you got a hoodie
to give away we're gonna close this
thing out down the road with air pods
but let them know what we need it's our
favorite time of the show
what i need you guys to do is get in the
comments let us know if you're rocking
with me let us know if you rock with my
boy connor
but uh yeah just type it get into it let
actually give us a take give us a bowl
bet as well
but um connor are you ready man let's
you ready to get right to it brother
let's get right into it and i had to
send this in before i found out who our
squad ride
winner was even going to be because we
do that on the show and i sent in the
boldest bet when things kick off on
saturday so i went with jamar chase our
squad ride leader not to score once but
to score
twice here greg plus 600 he has not
scored in a couple of weeks but you
nailed it in the beginning to say he's
been knocking on the door the catches
are there the yards are there especially
those yards after the catch so jamar
chase plus 600 to get in the end zone
not once not twice now i know you teased
your boldest bet you kept the people
hanging around waiting to find out what
it's gonna be what do you got for
conference championship weekend
i'm in la
i'm in l.a connor 49ers
rams i will be in attendance so i want
to talk about that game i want to talk
about those san francisco 49ers they
have beaten this rams team six time in a
row
they have beaten this rams team
twice this season
beating the team three times in one
season is a tough tough task
but the way that this san francisco
49ers team runs the ball
the way that the san francisco 49ers
teams plays defense and the way that the
san francisco 49ers team matched up
against these la rams in the past two
plus seasons
is giving me no other reason than to
believe that the san francisco 49ers is
going to come down to sofie stadium and
it's going to be full of red the stadium
is going to be full i mean full of red
and i'm gonna have my red on too
i'm gonna have my red on too at the game
connor hold on don't
the hat don't want me to be great but
we're gonna be great it's gonna be full
of red and the niners are gonna walk out
of there with a victory so take the
alternate spread don't take the money
line
you can take the safe bet in the spread
you could take that parlay and do
whatever you want to but take the
alternate spread right here it's plus
minus i know it's plus
175 it's gonna be a red out and so far
today connor and uh i'm rocking with the
gang man
greg is ready to go he's not taking
niners
plus points he's taking niners not
taking niners money line he's going with
smart strategy
at the win buy a field goal just in case
that goes into overtime greg that's the
play that's the way to do it
now
i know you're excited but i still need
you to give away these hoodies in this
jersey before you head to the game so we
got to get in the handy dandy the hat
stays on greg's rolling with niners
minus two and a half we want to know
guys which boldest bets are you rocking
with let greg know right now you're
going with the niners to win by lisa
field goal you're going with jamar chase
and you can go with either of them
separate games doesn't matter
i gotta take the hat off because i gotta
think right here i gotta think about who
i'm trying to hook up with this hoodie
and also giving away a jersey and are we
giving away some air pods too oh my gosh
all right here we go
i got i got boylo i'm rocking with
connor beating the team three times in
the season is so hard to see happen i
honestly i agree ko
therefore you're walking away with the
hoodie because i agree but i just think
it's the playoffs so things happen in
the playoffs uh uh we also got trine
nail says connor has got a great take
jamar uh oh
it just went away the comments just went
away you guys could see it on your
screen lying
i i mentioned i mentioned his name
producers please remember his name give
him a hoodie uh
let's move on let's move on i got logan
logan l three i g z says mahomes over
400 passing yards and three tds fire
rocking with greg faye connor no we're
not fading conor good vibes only um
that that that's that right there is
getting the hoodie i'm not a hoodie a
jersey i'm sorry that right there is
deserving of a jersey connor
brother i'm ready to get to this game
i'm ready to get to this game i'm ready
to go uh watch this this this matchup
later today actually the first match up
is is minutes away
and i'm ready i'm ready to turn on this
tv and get it started man
yeah it's about that time we get up on
out of here but
before we do
the good vibes roll on because we got
airpod pros to give away and we're
looking for something very simple we
want to know the best bets to win the
super bowl let's take a look at the
current championship odds right now as
it stands heading into the conference
championship games the chiefs plus 125
rams plus 200
niners sitting there a little bit of a
gap at plus 450 and then the bengals
looking way down the board at plus 800.
so if you want to get in on these airpod
pros greg let them know what they got to
do right now
i need you to guys to get in the
comments and tell me your locks to win
the championship we're going to spin the
wheel and if your comment matches the
team chosen by the wheel
you yes you could win a pair of airpod
pros
i'm jealous
i'm about to comment right now actually
hopefully my comment gets chosen
and you got to be right now the wheel is
going to be random
i'm going to throw my pick in here and
then greg i want yours and then let's
waste no time and spin the wheel i'm
playing the odds i you know in august
when greg and i uh with a lot of
different guests did our show
i was rolling with the rams
as one of my futures pick but as it
stands right now if i was playing this
board
i like the niners i like the niners over
there at plus 400 plus 450 right around
there
i think that's the odds of play sure the
chiefs are the easy chalky pick not that
great at odds if you're feeling real
bold you go with the bengals i like the
niners greg i know you do too i really
don't even have to ask but i will anyway
before we get this wheel going
hey connor i know i know you remember we
had v y we had a keep to leave on
and we were going through this before
the season before the season brother and
everybody was going through their super
bowl picks and i said the 49ers and
everybody started laughing at me talking
about we don't got no quarterback this
this and that
but look at us now look at us now we are
here down to this
it's come down to this you guys know i
got a future ticket i got them to win
the nfc i got a future ticket on the nfc
also got a feeder ticket on the super
bowl i'm not gonna i'm rocking with the
niners man i think that they have the
identity
they have they they have the identity as
a team of what it takes to win a super
bowl run the football play defense
i'm rocking with the boys from san
francisco connor
all right let's get it going let's get
the wheels spinning you know the deal by
now if the wheel lands on your
team that you picked in the comments
you have a chance to win the airpod pros
so let's waste no time
let's get this thing going 25 chance it
lands on 14
in this and then greg's gonna take it
away and give out the air pods and we
got
the rams the rams the wheel is going
with the last time we did this they did
not go with the rams
this is a uh
the wheel is fading you greg the wheel
is fading you
that's fine that that's absolutely fine
uh
the wheels faded me
that's fine but i want to see okay i got
okay here we go
j fry 14 14 says sorry greg there he is
sorry greg not this time with the rams
laughing
there it is guess what
guess what you were walking away with
some airpods brother it's love on this
side uh you're walking away with airpods
shout out to you shout out to the to the
rams they're not gonna win today
that's a wrap j fry greg's telling you
your team's gonna lose but as a
consolation you get airpod pros pretty
sweet deal and for those winners don't
worry vr betting is gonna dm you in the
next 24 to 48 hours if greg shouted you
out for a hoodie a jersey the airpods
you know the deal by now we've given out
prizes non-stop on this show and it will
not stop there we will be back for super
bowl sunday at the same time 11 a.m
eastern shout out to our lock legends uh
make sure
if you haven't yet get on draftkings
it's your first time five dollars to win
280 the moneyline promo throw a money
line bet get those bonus bet money it's
free money it's free money if you're in
louisiana bet on joe burrow to complete
a pass it's free money it's got to be
joe burrow has to complete a pass and
don't first forget about the no score
first drive in rams niners boosted
to plus 200 and also don't forget jamar
chase boosted the plus 125 that's what
we do on the show we're making it easier
for you to bet please send us your
reaction videos and drop your real-time
takes on social in the br betting app
the community stream and once again join
us super bowl sunday two weeks 11 a.m
eastern time i'm connor rogers he's greg
ivory see you in two weeks
[Music]
you